E
CAN EXPECT TO HAVE THAT IN 2024
IN OTHER STATES.
MY ONLY POINT IS THAT THE
TURNOUT WAS INTERESTING.
HE HAD THE NUMBER ONE IF MY
ISSUE IN THE COUNTRY WAS
INFLATION.
SOME CHANGE BUT THERE DOES LOOK
LIKE THEY'RE GOING TO BE ANY
POLICY CHANGES FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE >> I'M JUST GLAD MY
RED WAVE PREDICTION WAS
ACCURATE.
>> Greg: HOW MUCH MONEY DO
YOU...
100, A THOUSAND WILL GO TO
CHARITY, DONE IT MANY PEOPLE ME
AS A CHARITY CASE, SO WE'LL SEE.
TO THE WATERS FOUNDATION.
NO, I'LL PAY UP.
>> GIVE US YOUR TAKE OVER ALL.
>> THE HOUSE IS NOW IN
McCARTHY'S HANDS, PELOSI WILL
PROBABLY GO TO ROME TO BE
AMBASSADOR AND THAT'S FINE AND
THERE WILL BE INVESTIGATIONS AND
THAT'S GOOD.
I WAS DISAPPOINTED IN THE SENATE
OUTCOME BECAUSE OF THE POLLS
SHOWED IT WAS GOOD TO BE 52-53.
IF YOU LOOK WHAT HAPPENED IN
PENNSYLVANIA, I CANNOT BELIEVE
JOHN FETTERMAN ONE!
I CANNOT BELIEVE IT!
I HONESTLY CANNOT BELIEVE THEY
VOTED FOR THIS GUY!
ABORTION WAS CRITICAL IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
I DIDN'T SEE IT WAS GOOD BE THAT
CRITICAL.
OURS WAS NOT A GREAT CANDIDATE.
HE HAD A BRUTAL PRIMARY, HE TOOK
THE SUMMER OFF AND CAMPAIGNED
HARD AT THE END.
BUT PEOPLE DIDN'T TRUST THEM.
THEY DIDN'T TRUST THE GUY.
HE WAS IN FOR PENNSYLVANIA.
AND IT WAS FRAUD HE LENT THE WAY
FEDERMAN HID HIS CONDITION AND
SKIPPED THIS DEBATE.
BY THAT TIME THEY BANKED SO MANY
EARLY VOTES.
SO REPUBLICANS REALLY HAVE TO
GET A HOLD OF THIS EARLY VOTE
THING.
THERE'S NO REPUBLICAN REPUBLICAN
EARLY VOTE STRATEGY.
CAN ANYBODY TELL ME WHAT THAT
IS?
REPUBLICANS VOTE ON
ELECTION DAY.
DEMOCRATS VOTE FOR FIVE WEEKS.
SO THERE'S THIS MASS
MOBILIZATION CAMPAIGN THAT'S
UNDERWAY IN THESE EARLY VOTING
STATES AND REPUBLICANS ARE
SITTING ABOUT.
THEY GET SOULS IN THE POLLS IN
PHILLY AS THEY SAY, THEY'RE
KNOCKING ON DOORS, THIS PAPER
EVERYWHERE, WHAT'S THE
REPUBLICAN PLAN CHRIS MARK I
DON'T KNOW SO THEY NEED TO PLAN
FOR THAT.
GEORGE I'M NERVOUS ABOUT.
LOOKS LIKE LASSO IS GOING TO
HOLD ON NEVADA, MASTERS IS
COOKED IN ARIZONA.
SO IT'S GEORGIA RUNOFF AGAIN.
SO THIS IS ABOUT HERSCHEL
WALKER.
AND...
SPEED TO BECAUSE IT'S ABOUT
ABORTIONS...
>> THEY CRUSHED HIM ON THESE
ABORTION ATTACKS.
THIS WILL BE ANOTHER NAIL-BITER
AND IT MAKES ME VERY NERVOUS.
YOU ALSO HAVE GOOD RACES RUN BY
RON JOHNSON, HE'S IN THERE AND
HE'S GOING TO INVESTIGATE THE
HELL OUT OF THE BIDEN CRIME
FAMILY AND THAT'S GOOD.
BUT A NEW VENTURE STOMACH
NEW HAMPSHIRE THAT GUY GOT
RAILROADED.
YOU PUT UP A GUY WHO'S RUNNING
FOR GOVERNOR IN PENNSYLVANIA WHO
JUST GOT SLAUGHTERED.
THESE THINGS HAVE DOWN BALLOT
CONSEQUENCES, IT HURTS OZ,
REPUBLICAN HOUSE CANDIDATE.
CELLO DOME EXCELLED INTO GREAT
CONSIDERING IT'S A BLUE STATE,
LOCAL HEAD HELP FROM EVERY
CROOKED DEMOCRATIC CAME IN TO
SAVE HER AND SHE BARELY HELD ON
BUT SELDEN HAD COOKED HILLS AND
GOT A BUNCH OF HOUSE REPUBLICANS
IN THERE.
LOOKS LIKE A BUNCH MORE HOUSE
REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO COME
INTO THE WEST COAST.
YOU THINK THIS IS GONNA BE A
NAIL-BITER?
THERE CAN HAVE THE HOUSE AND IS
NOT GOING TO BE THE BIGGEST
MARGIN OF ALL TIME BUT IT'S
GONNA BE BIGGER THAN THEY SAY IT
IS RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS THE RED WAVE IF YOU'RE
LOOKING AT FLORIDA, STACY'S NO
LONGER WITH US SHE'S GONNA GO
BACK TO WRITING EROTIC NOVELS.
BYE-BYE, FIND ANOTHER OFFICE.
THERE'S JUST NOT THE HATRED FOR
JOE BIDEN THE WAY THERE IS FOR
OBAMA AND THE CLINTONS.
WHEN YOU GO, THERE'S TROMP ON
THE BALLOT, THERE IS A HATE
CHOMP PASSION.
PEOPLE FEEL THE SAME PASSION
WITH THESE OTHERS.
SINGLE WOMEN ARE VOTING FOR
DEMOCRATS BY 30 POINTS.
>> 37 POINTS.
AND IN URBAN AMERICA THERE
CLEANING OUR CLOCKS IN THE
CITIES.
THEY ARE CLEANING OUR CLOCKS IN
THE CITIES.
WERE GIVING IT AWAY.
THE FACT THAT THESE YOUTH
FLOATERS ARE COMING IN SO STRONG
IN AN OFF IS VERY CONCERNING.
IT LOOKS LIKE THEY'VE BEEN
BRAINWASHED.
THIS NEW GENERATION IS
ALL OF THE SINGLE WOMEN VOTE 37
SPREADS FOR DEMOCRATS OR
TEACHING.
THE YOUNGER GENERATION ARE IN
THE SCHOOLS AND THEIR POLLUTING
MINDS.
THEY GROW UP IN THEIR IN THEIR
20s AND THEY VOTE FOR
LEFTISTS.
[LAUGHS]
>> Greg: I CAN'T GET WRAPPED
UP IN THIS.
I DON' PROBLEM IS.
I DIDN'T NEED A RED WAVE.
I IMPLORED PEOPLE TO BE
REALISTIC.
WHAT YOU'RE SEEING RIGHT HERE IS
THAT DEMOCRATS ARE THRILLED
BECAUSE THEIR EXPECTATIONS WERE
DISASTROUS.
AND REPUBLICANS ARE A BIT BUMMED
BECAUSE THEIR EXPECTATIONS WERE
TOO HIGH.
RIGHT CHRIS MARKWOOD THAT'S WHAT
YOU'RE SEEING.
EVERYBODY GOT A LITTLE PLEASED,
EVERYBODY GOT A LITTLE
DISAPPOINTED.
I'M HAPPY REPUBLICANS FLIPPED
SOME SEATS, I'M HAPPY ABOUT
DeSANTIS, ABBOTT, I'M BUMMED
ABOUT A LOCAL, I'M SELDEN PUT
CREME FRAICHE STOMACH FRONT AND
CENTER, THAT PUSHED NEW YORK TO
THE RIGHT.
THE FACT IS...
>> THE ONLY THING THAT MATTERS,
THAT'S THE POINT, IS THE HOUSE.
A WIN IS A WIN.
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE A RED WAVE
BUT IF YOU WANT THE
INVESTIGATIONS, IF YOU WANT YOUR
HANDS ON THE PURSE STRINGS, IF
YOU WANT NATIONAL GOT FILLED
DAY, THE SENATE IS LESS
IMPORTANT.
IT WOULD'VE BEEN COOL.
BUT THIS IS WHAT IT IS.
IT'S NOT THE END OF DEMOCRACY.
THAT'S A FUNNY THING ABOUT THIS.
PEOPLE WERE WHIPPED UP INTO A
FRENZY THAT DEMOCRACY WAS
COMING.
WHAT IT IS IS, PEOPLE GET
DISAPPOINTED, THEY GOT PLEASE.
IT'S NOT SO BAD.
NOW I GOT A BALANCE OF POWER.
YOU GOT BIDEN IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, THE REPUBLICANS ON
THE PURSE STRINGS, THAT'S GOOD.
>> Dana: THE DEMOCRAT SPENT A
LOT OF TIME AND MONEY SAYING
REPUBLICANS WOULDN'T ACCEPT THE
RESULTS IF THEY LOST BUT THAT
HASN'T HAPPENED.
>> Greg: PEOPLE CARE LESS
ABOUT THE ACTUAL FUNCTIONING OF
A CANDIDATE THAN WHETHER THEY
CAN WIN.
AS NANCY PELOSI ONCE SAID, THE
GLASS OF WATER, YOU REMEMBER
THAT ABOUT AOC.
SHE SAID YOU CAN RUN A GLASS OF
WATER AND IT WOULD WIN.
>> THEY WANT ME TO PLAY THE
SOUND OR THERE IN A FIRE ME.
IT'S FROM PRESIDENT BIDEN AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THIS IS WHAT HE SAID ABOUT 2024,
WHICH IS OUR NEXT ELECTION.
>> President Biden: THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY OUTPERFORMED
BEYOND WHAT ANYONE EXPECTED.
IT GIVES EVERYONE A SIGH OF
RELIEF THAT THE MEGA MEGA
REPUBLICANS ARE NOT TAKING OVER
THE GOVERNMENT AGAIN, ET CETERA.
SO MY JUDGMENT OF RUNNING WHEN I
ANNOUNCE, IF MY ANNOUNCE, MY
INTENTION IS THAT AROUND AGAIN,
BUT I'M A GREAT RESPECTER OF
FATE.
THIS IS ULTIMATELY A FAMILY
DECISION.
>> Dana: OKAY, WHAT DOES IT
MEAN JUDGE?
>> PRESIDENTS WHO HAVE SUFFERED
MORE CRUSHING MIDTERMS HAVE GONE
ON TO WIN A SECOND TERM.
JOE BIDEN TODAY IS LUCID, HE'S
UPBEAT, HAPPY.
HE'S READY TO ROLL AGAIN.
THAT'S WHAT CAME OUT OF THE
MIDTERMS.
THE RED WAVE, THE RED TIDE,
DOESN'T MATTER AT THIS POINT.
JOE BIDEN IS RUNNING AGAIN.
AND HAVE TO SAY ONE MORE THING.
THE THING THAT DISAPPOINTS ME IS
THAT YOU'VE GOT FEDERMAN COME UP
WHERE PEOPLE ARE VOTING
SEPTEMBER 19, THEY DON'T EVEN
SEE IF HE IS CAPABLE OR NOT.
KATIE HUBBS WILL NOT DEBATE
CARRIE LAKE.
SHE CAN BARELY PUT A SENTENCE
TOGETHER.
AND SHE IS CLOSE TO CARRIE
LAKE NOW BUT WHO KNOWS WHO'S
COUNTING IN ARIZONA.
I'M NOT GOING TO SAY WHETHER
PEOPLE WHO CAN'T READ OR
COUNTING OR NOT.
BUT JOE BIDEN IT STOMACH BIDEN
WAS IN THE BASEMENT, HE DIDN'T
COME OUT.
THE MORE YOU DEBATE THE MORE YOU
DELAY, THE MORE YOU'RE GOING TO
WIN.
>> Dana: YOU WANT TO TALK
ABOUT BIDEN 2024 FOR A MOMENT.
>> Greg: IT LOOKS LIKE HE'S
GONNA RUN HIM AFTER TALKS ABOUT
IT WITH JILL.
LOOKS LIKE TRUMP IS GOING ON
BECAUSE STOMACH RUN BECAUSE IT'S
A REMATCH.
IT LOOKS TOUGH FOR TRUMP IF YOU
LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED LAST
NIGHT.
SOME OF HIS CANDIDATES DIDN'T DO
WELL.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE THINKING
YOU PUT TOGETHER THIS MASSIVE
WORK CHEST AND DIDN'T SPEND THE
KIND OF MONEY THEY HOPE TO
SPEND.
AND YOU KNOW IT'S GONNA BRING
OUT THE CRAZIES ON THE LEFT.
I LOVE TRUMP.
I WANT TO RUN AGAIN.
I LOVED HIM AS PRESIDENT.
HE BRINGS OUT SOME INSANITY ON
THE LEFT AND NO WALKOVER HOT
COALS TO BEAT HIM.
BUT BIDEN DOESN'T INSPIRE THE
PASSION FROM THE RIGHT THAT YOU
WOULD EXPECT.
I CAN'T STAND THE GUY.
I THINK HE'S DESCRIBING THE COME
STOMACH COUNTRY ON THE BORDER,
THE DOLLAR...
>> BUT DEMOCRATS CAME OUT TO
VOTE.
SPEAK OUT THAT SOME ABORTION,
THE ECONOMY.
>> ONE OF THINGS THAT WOULD BE
DIFFERENT IF JOE BIDEN RUNS THIS
TIME IS THAT COVID WILL BE BACK
I HOPE AND HE WOULD HAVE TO BE
BACK OUT ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
>> Greg: NO.
THERE'D BE ANOTHER STRAIN OF
COVID.
IT WOULD BE COVID 2023.
HE'LL BE HERMETICALLY SEALED,
BIDEN, PROBABLY IN AN ESOPHAGUS.
I DON'T BUY ANY OF THIS.
TWO YEARS.
THAT'S A LONG TIME.
WE'VE WATCHED HIM DEGRADE OVER
PERIODS OF MONTHS IN THE NEEDS
COMING BACK NEEDS LUCID OR
WHATEVER.
TWO YEARS IS LONG TIME FOR
REPUBLICANS AS WELL.
TRUMP, I GIVE THEM 80% THAT IS
GOING TO RUN.
I ALSO THINK DeSANTIS IS RIGHT
NOW THE GUY, HE'S A DIFFERENT
ARRIVAL THAN THE OTHERS BECAUSE
HE'S A STRONG GOVERNOR WHO JUST
WHIPPED CHARLIE CRIST.
>> BUT HE COULD GET BRUTALIZED
OR ANNIHILATED AGAINST TRUMP.
THE VOTERS IN THESE PRIMARY
STATES, IN THE SOUTH, CRITICAL
BATTLE GROUND STATES, THOUGH
VOTE FOR TRUMP OVER DeSANTIS.
>> Dana: WHAT ABOUT DEMOCRATS
ARE THEY COMFORTABLE WITH BIDEN
RUNNING IN 24 CHRIS BURKE >> I
WOULD SEE US OVERALL BASED ON
LAST NIGHT'S RESULTS.
BUT IT'S WHAT WHAT'S EXCITING TO
ME IS THE QUESTION OF WHERE IS
THE BENCH?
GRETCHEN WHITMER EMMA REGAN AT
TALK ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED IN
FLORIDA, SHE...
>> Greg: SHE DID WIN, BUT...
>> Dana: SORRY.
OKAY.
I TAKE IT BACK.
SORRY.
[LAUGHS]
>> Greg: SORRY IT DOESN'T WORK
THAT WAY.
>> JOSH SHAPIRO, WHO IS AN
INCREDIBLE CANDIDATE, AND
TIM RYAN, WHO LOST BUT REALLY
SHOWED PEOPLE THE PATH OF HOW
YOU CAN CAMPAIGN IN THE STATE
LIKE OHIO.
THESE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE
AROUND.
THE THERE APPEALING.
>> THERE WAS AN IMPRESSION ON A
IMPRESSIVE BUNCH OF REPUBLICANS
WHO HAVE ONE AS WELL.
YOU HAVEN'T HEARD THEIR NAMES
YET BUT YOU GET TO KNOW THEM.
WE HAD SOME GOOD DIVERSITY.
THE EXAM STOMACH EXAMPLE IS THE
NUMBER OF WOMEN WHO RUN, IS A
LATINA CANDIDATE KEVIN